안녕하세요 Steve Kaufman 저는
오늘 제 한국어 진행 상황에 대해 조금 이야기하고 링크
에 있는 우리 튜터 중 한 명과 나눈 토론을 게시할
것입니다. 제
한국어 배경은 시작하기 약 6년 전입니다.
러시아어 나는 Ross King이 여기
에서 출판한 UBC의 책을 포함하여 다양한 책을 사용하여 하루에 1시간씩 약 6개월을 보냈습니다
.
나는 그것이 중급 한국어라고 생각
하지만 찾을 수 있는 교과서가 무엇이든
스스로 가르칠 수 있습니다. 나는 SML을 시도
했지만 매우 나빴습니다.  아주 지루한
음 들어 들어 들어 들어 들어 읽어
듣고 그렇게 6개월 정도
하다가 크러신에 빠져서
지금은 한국으로 돌아와서
11월 중순쯤 또 1시간 정도 거리를 두고 하고 있어요
오늘 한국어에 대한 문제는
여전히 러시아어와 수표를 유지하려고 노력하고
있으므로
일주일에 한 번 정도 체코어 또는 러시아어로 말하려고 노력하고
여전히 매일 내 메아리를 주로
듣고 당신의 말을 듣습니다.  체코어를 알다  dio
content so my and and 일부
이유는 거기에서
어려움을 겪거나
한국어로 흥미로운
콘텐츠를 찾는 데
어려움을 겪었기 때문입니다.
러시아나 체코
라디오에서 대통령 선거 얘기 등의 사건에 대해 이야기를
하고 있는데,
늘 그렇듯이 공부
를 하던 언어에서
벗어나 점점 더 헌신하기까지 시간이 걸린다.  새로운
언어에 운 좋게도 당신은 우리
의 이름이 그녀의 이름인 순간의 긴 회원이 있다는 것을 알고
있지만 그녀는 이벤트에 기여합니다
괜찮습니다 그녀는
한국어 학습을 위한 많은 좋은 콘텐츠를 로드했고
잠시 동안 나는 러시아의 목소리 자료를 사용하고
있었지만 지금은  그녀는
훨씬 더 좋은 자료를 업로드하기 시작했습니다. 이
[음악]
무료 조선
은 그들이 북한 사람들에게 전한 메시지라고 생각
하지만
라디오는 매우 좋습니다.  러시아의 목소리는 너무 무거운
선전이며 소련이 없던
시절부터 그들은
보라색 고구마 재배와 같은 러시아의 놀라운 기술 혁신에 대해 이야기하고 있거나
전력을 위해 수련을 분해하는 것을 모르거나
러시아 시스템이 왜 그런지 알지 못합니다.
네비게이션 시스템이나 무인
교통이 미국 시스템보다 낫
거나 한국인이 한글이 그렇게 독특
하다고 생각하는 것이 어리석다는 말
은
믿을 수 없을 정도로 무거운 선전
이지만
오디오와 텍스트라는 이점이 있으며 물론  내가 필요한
것은 오디오 텍스트이고 단순한 학습자 유형의 어휘에 지쳤기 때문에 당신이 둔한 어휘를 알고 있습니다.
그러나 라디오 무료 선택이 훨씬
더 낫
습니다.  echo
는 러시아어와 수표에 대한 나의 연구
에서 틀림없지만
나의 성공에 있어 결정적인 요인은 성인용 정통 콘텐츠에 대한 액세스였습니다.
ch에는 오디오와
텍스트가 있었고
러시아어의 경우 링크에서 가져올 수 있었습니다. 오디오북
톨스토이 등이 있었고 버지니아와 eka가
있어야 했고 확인의 경우 체스 Kairos 클래스에서 사용할 수
있는 다양한 역사와 정치
자료였습니다.
그래서 시간 호텔
라디오 무료 Tosun인 이 새로운 소스가
나를 위해 그것을 할 것입니다 왜냐하면 나는
당신이 내가 검토할 수 있다는 것을 알기 때문입니다 나는
문법 책을 가지고 있습니다 나는 패턴을 검토할 수
있지만 그것들은 고착되지 않고
체코와 러시아어에 대한 나의 경험  내 말
은 누출에 대한 내 통계를 읽으면 내가
수십만 단어와 수표를 읽었고
러시아어로 150,000 단어 이상을 읽었다는 것을 알
수 있다는 것입니다.
내가 읽고 들을 수 있는 흥미로운 콘텐츠가
있고
이 방대한 듣기 및 읽기에 충분
하면 다양한 패턴이 결국
에는
너무 자주 들었기
때문에 자연스럽게 자연스러워집니다.  링컨에서 그것들을 구하고
이 단어들과 구절들 중 일부를 검토하기 위해 노력
하지만
다시 나에게 의미 있는 의미 있는 콘텐츠 콘텐츠에서 나온 것이므로
한국어로 이러한 종류의 콘텐츠를 찾을 수 있다면 당신이
있기 때문에 향상될 수 있기를 바랍니다.
내가 한국에서 나를 표현하는 데 많은 어려움을 겪는다는 것을 알고 있는 이 짧은 클립을 볼 때 당신이 알게 될 것입니다.
만약 내가 이 단어를 한국에서
여러 번 더 많이 듣지 않았다면 특정 단어의 발음이 너무 이상했습니다.  많은
다른 맥락에서 내가 이것을 듣고
다른 맥락에서 이 패턴을 읽는
다면 그것들은
나에게
더 자연스러울 것입니다.
말하기를 시작하기 전에
실제로 속도를 늦추겠습니다. 링크를 연결
하는 3명의 다른 튜터와 함께 일주일에 세
번씩 이야기하고 있었습니다.  t
언더  tand 내 한국어 튜터가
말하는 내용 우리는 어른
스럽고 차분하고 의미 있는 대화를 하려고 노력하고 있지만
당신이 말하는 것을 이해할 수 있으므로
너무 많은 시간을 말하기 전에 이해를 높여야
한다고 생각합니다.
내 시간을 더 투자하는 것이
내 이해력을 향상시키는 데 투자하는 것이 좋습니다.
여기에는 싸우는 것보다 어휘력을 향상하는 것이 포함됩니다.
내 엉망진창 Xin
Korean과 앞으로 몇 개월 안에 하나를 올릴
수 있기를 바랍니다. 만약 내가
많은 듣기 읽기에 할애할 시간을 찾을 수 있다면
우리는 약간의 진전을 볼 수
있을 것입니다. 듣기에 감사드립니다.
I know I know oh uh I'  네게 말해줄게 알았어
Geneseo 이 파일에 있는 모든 관계
오 오늘은 신에게 맹세코 말해줘
Tina Sunita hey t-bone Hangul 그들은 em을 봤다
병아리 너 건방진 Jonica 확실히 예 내가 전화를
끊었다 나는 klöden을 보았다 너 귀엽다 taco
em Veronica Caruso 그럼 나 사실이야  티
경적을 울리는 Danny Troy Troy kannababu Donna
와 고문 공동 작성자 Kannada m2k choke
Tara 진정해 oh yeah Year Zero
hoodie Vancouver는 꺼져 있습니다 - Tiana는
잘 시작하려고 하는 사람
은 없습니다.  Crona 헤이 Nate Chiba와
즐길 수 Sun Sun Sun 엄마
아들 나는 Tyrone Charo Sashi
Boone on
noni money Sun God 헤이 헤이 아빠
이란을 확인하십시오 Sana의 오프 스키 선수 Oh Cassidy
Cassidy
I do it just me
yes no Edie Holloway jigum or ando  안도
온도
예 정시에 oh no what not how do you
say yeah ii 어떻게 해야할지 모르겠어
oh yo hi oh 어서 don't you want Johan
Johan don't do I'm better Deb right
Donna
ah ah  yo chill todo o yo
총체적으로 we chill to date 알로하
너의 마음은 you go oh hello children go
jana chuda John go nacho Sameera to
Sunday La Canada is Oh Cho katana tada
Chad you can do a cannon a uh tabata a
lotta  air Oh cock it's all yo ha you
ship Tom Jesus it ne-san이 보내졌어
맙소사, 집에 가자고 말해봐 그래서 ok yo ha
Sasha는 yo가 달성했다고 말했잖아 아니면
난 기뻐해 스키를 한 번 해볼게
Agee 난 껌을 씹을게
아니요 잊어
버렸어요
예 당신은 무슨 일인지 예 그가
식물이나 어떤 사람을 보냈는지 알아요
예 Kumba Chango 내가 말하겠습니다
Antigone이 말하고 Acharya
가 당신을 때리는 것을 지켜보면서 여기로 와서 코칭을 받게 될 것입니다
우리의 T 계산을 시작하는
당신  그리고 당신에게 oh ah yes
거기에 핀이 있어 hey 싸구려 방법 up man big
and one j1j a fiend and a cut
come o ki ki ki - Myka um Kohaku Bonin
Yoram Tony Stark
난 이미 doc 당신이 그리워요 당신은 남자이고 그때 당신을 찔렀습니다
하하
- Alma Cogan Alma to run clean and a salgo a
kiss can I Kiss Amica 슬픔
oh no 슬픔 Google Google Haruka
Myung ha ha
양파 혼자 하지마
거기에 어린 팬을 넣어 ah Tommy I'm
panning de jambe Nathaniel don't Oh 말썽쟁이
자매 Cassandra가 들어와 숙제를 마쳤
습니다 II 죄송
합니다 ru Timmy's or y'all ba  by ah
are you uh 어떻게 말합니까 이봐 Danny는
당신이고 어떻게 봅니까
이봐 젊은 신이 나갔어 야 이
거시기 저기 아래에
Kumu aggy gosh 그래 안돼 더 이상 oh yeah
내가 가졌어 난 악마가 문에 있어 오 이리와
컵에 여기 boo 여기 컵에 당신은 호보가 아니라
당신은 더 많은 oh oh yes piña d' Oro
boo boo ha 하 당신은 가고 있습니다 Singh Karki
Sumida 양파 더 많은 dosa
가 meh에게 anatolia의 알약을 말할 것입니다
mm-hmm  Dean and a mutt Hong Kong that's It's
Huggy party 어떻게 가는지 봐요
uh 호텔
비즈니스 oh no no no hmm yes chillin
chillin Magic Kingdom door to moon ah
man 대답은 Myka yo yo Julia
choko choko choko come chou-  heung go go Buddha
큰 선택 uh 양파 hey Quentin 난
악마와 가신 chingle chingle
dream on e in ambien poly yeah you
changhie 또 다른 엄마 집 ooh man
안아줘
Anita no time yeah right
um right
you got money kumbaya me  난 글로리아야
오 그래
알았어 옴니 그들이 나에게 말할 수 있는
시간이 온다 남자가 온다  age orgy a
addictive I do che meanin wait
yagi Jamie oh yeah ye and 슬픔 포옹
이유 man this middle ah yes on
samhita on you
안녕히 가세요 yeah and they say oh
OK